a lighthouse appears and a storm shelter
door opens a nanny emerges from the
shelter
coming
in the rocks
I'm sorry I'm sorry I think I missed
some of those words oh I was trying a
Scottish dialect uh-huh
because the nannies The Nanny refers to
a childhood in Aberdeen
right
it's okay to try things let's just go
again a nanny emerges from the shelter
storm's coming
don't see his at night for roaming on
the rocks
French Canadian
because it's up in the maritimes there
so
a lot of French I'm sorry it's this is
my process it's just how I find the
nanny's voice you know what maybe we try
it slightly more how you talk
a nanny emerges from the shelter
ah
storms coming
don't think it's a night for roaming on
the rocks
I don't go roaming anywhere
oh my God it's me
oh I'm sorry it's me isn't it it's it's
your line yes
[Music]